Wow.
the
that
you
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Hey,
Uh.
Oh, wait, wait, where's my- I lost my phone for chat, um, oh, let me try to find it,
I just had it with me, oh, it was underneath me, hi, hello, I can see you now, I can see
you now, hi, I'm sorry for being late, I know we're like 15 minutes late now, sorry, I um,
I um, I still haven't bounced back, exactly, not yet, um, it wouldn't be an Emmy stream
without you being a little late, as no- are none of the other girls ever late, I feel
I feel like they are sometimes, right, I mean maybe I'm the latest, I don't know,
it's okay, we can wait if it means getting the live, yeah, sorry, I accidentally started,
I accidentally started the live and then um, ended, like right away, I started it and then ended it,
and that's what happened and that's why I had to restart it, like an idiot, so that, yeah,
we were just early, and we say something cringe for you, cringe, I don't know what cringe stuff
to say, it's gotta come naturally, you know, yeah, you need like 15 minutes for people to pile in
anyways, people, people, you know, people will pile in and they take time, let me um, switch over to
um, oh, hi, that doesn't look quite right, let me scooch this down, okay, now I'm wearing gloves
today, um, I got an ad on my own stream so I can't see what's happening, I can't, um, give me gloves,
yeah, um, I forgot what I was going to say to be honest, um, well today we're painting this
shirt for my mom, gloves to protect from pants, no, gloves because I'm feeling self-conscious,
I don't know why, I feel like, I feel like I have so many lights around me and yet the
stream still looks really dark, like, here let me move this mouse, maybe I shouldn't put that there,
where do I put chat, I'll put chat right there, do you like my phone case, I got a new phone case,
isn't it cute, and I got a little mushroom charm, it's got, it's a little mushroom with a
strawberry uh, strawberry purse, very cute, um, what was I saying, I feel like it's the, the camera
looks so dark and I don't know why, because I'm surrounded by lights, like I have this huge light
right next to me, and then I also have like a big ring light right here where I'm pointing at the
camera, so I don't know, I don't know, it's very in season, yeah, because it's um, what is it,
but it's gonna be September soon, in like 10 days I think,
I have to look up for chat, oh no nevermind my chat came back,
release the fingers, no, the gloves aren't pretty silky though, I like them, they look dirty,
but it's just my skin tone like peeking through, because like I got them a little wet from the
drink, we're drinking um, loho of last in this really rubbed off, off really, really rubbed off
hello kitty cup, with the straw barely able to get to the top of the cup, um, okay right, so my mom
asked me to paint her a shirt, because my cousin painted her dad a shirt, and my mom was like,
oh Amy you've painted shirts before, why don't you paint, why don't you ever paint me a shirt,
so now I'll have to paint a shirt for her, um, you buy your gear subs using the 10% off code, Amy,
that's funny, um, yes you should do that though, if you buy it you should do it, you should use
my cup, no that's weird to say, um, I have painted one shirt before when I was in high school, let
me, I don't know if I can still find it, it's in my closet which is literally right there, um,
I'll try looking for it, give me a second,
okay, I just tore apart my whole closet to find this shirt, um,
this is what I painted, this is my, it's traced, okay I didn't, I didn't come up with this myself,
it's traced from the internet, but this is what I painted on my first ever, um, shirt,
it's really cute right, I'm pretty proud of it, I mean I didn't draw it myself, but I feel
like the, the quality is there, it has some holes in it from my rats, but the quality is there,
like it, it looks good, you know, it came out really really good, yeah, I can't guarantee that
this one will come out good, because I'm not gonna put as much effort, this took me like two days
to make, okay, I'm not gonna put, we're not putting that much effort today, impressive self-portrait,
it's not me, it's not me, you can really feel the emotion, I'm gonna throw that away, okay, I'm,
I'm gonna look on like Pinterest, my idea, my idea is my mom likes cats,
that's the same design on your mom, oh doing the same design on your mom's, no she doesn't want that,
um, my mom likes cats a lot,
but when we went out on vacation, she went to this really shitty store and she found like
kids shirts with like a, like a kid's shirt with like sparkles and a cat on it, and she was like,
look at me isn't this so cute, and I was like, I guess so for like a first grader, and she was like,
well it's cute, oh I forgot to put on my headphones, thank you for the ten dollars,
okay let me put on my headphones, oh there's my, ah, okay hold on,
where the fuck are my headphones,
huh,
oh there they are,
I hope this is steady, ah, I'm really, my biggest fear is like this coming out, and showing my ugly mug,
um, where,
what am I looking for right now, oh I know,
there we go,
no, she's gonna hate an Ahegao shirt, we wouldn't tell, good, good,
there's no way little sis can be ugly, oh,
keep living in that fantasy land,
no I don't think I'll draw a tin pal, I'm really not trying to expose myself here,
um, what I think I'll do
is um, I'm gonna go on Pinterest right now, and I'm gonna, um,
go on,
I'm gonna look for a cute picture of a cat, I'm thinking of drawing like those um,
what's it called, you know those like pocket cats that like stick their tongue out,
I'm thinking of drawing something like that, except not their tongue sorry, stick their middle
finger out, I think I'll draw something like that, um, except I won't put the middle finger,
I don't know, she's kind of like, she's kind of, she's not really that cool, if that makes sense,
I don't know, I feel like she's not cool enough to like the cat with the middle finger,
like she wants something like kind of, what does it mean to say ugly, she wants something kind of,
kind of like something you would find in like, oh my god,
okay there we go, um,
she wants something you would find in like a children's clothing store,
you know, um, cute cat, um,
what's like that word that you use, grumpy cat, no, I don't think she wants grumpy cat, um,
let me see what I can find, these are like,
should I draw her this, do you think she'd like that,
I don't know, I, she's not internet enough to know, I gotta draw something like,
that looks more obviously like a cat,
oh, man, but these internet cats look so cute, like this one, look how cute this one is,
man, if fully she was a little bit more like, on the internet, she would understand,
but instead she would be like, um, is this a cat, is this supposed to be a cat,
oh wow, thanks Amy, I love it, you know what I mean, I can't give her that,
um, maybe a black cat,
I could draw like the cat from,
um,
something like this, something cute like that, right, at least your mom loves you, damn, okay,
no matter how much to that, Kiki's, yeah, like Kiki's like a little circle with the kitty like that,
that would be really cute, right, I think I'll do that, I'll do it like right here, like on the,
on the boob area, like right, or maybe on,
hold on, if you put, like on the heart area, I don't know, one side of it,
yeah, plain and simple, something cute and simple and plain and cute,
oops, hold on, I gotta put the glove back on, it doesn't work on the, like I can't use my phone
if I'm wearing it, oh I should go back to, oh wait, no, how do I save this, how do I download image,
also I forgot to show you, I got this commission of me as a cat, wait,
I got this commission of me as a cat, do you like it,
it's really cute, right, tell me it's cute, I think it's cute,
how do I like pin this to my screen, I forget, oh, Samsung's work,
I think if I like swipe, like swipe, there's like a side swipe you can do,
I thought there was a side swipe,
can someone help me, I would give her so many treats, can you make it a sticker, like sell it,
I don't think I'm allowed to sell it, it was just an average commission,
unless you mean like an email on YouTube, I'm trying to, I'm trying to pin this, like,
this is in my gallery, I'm trying to pin it to my screen so I can still look at YouTube,
how do I do that, I'm kind of a noob,
at least you got a mom, I'm adopted and my adopted parents put me up for adoption,
okay now you're trolling, now you're trolling, come on now,
if you open your open app screen, tap and hold the, on your,
what, oh, oh thank you, I got it, I got it, thank you, thank you so much, I got it,
okay let me put that in the corner, now I can still see it, yeah there we go,
my parents dropped me in the woods, I was raised by a pack of wolves, okay,
I don't know what to tell you man, are you trying to make me seem privileged here,
by not having not been raised by a pack of wolves,
send me to the wolves and I'll come back pregnant,
why do you look like you're ready for Halloween, what do you mean, are you talking about my blanket,
is that what you're talking about,
well, I just, that's just like, that's just like my style of decoration in my house,
I'm always, the house always looks like it's ready for Halloween, that's just how I decorate,
like all of my, not all of my blankets but like a lot of my blankets and stuff,
have that vibe, I guess I do kind of look like a scarecrow, huh, yeah I'm gonna do it on this up here,
on this shirt pocket,
I don't know, I have to like position this carefully, maybe like,
I feel like I'm gonna end up drawing it somewhere really awkward,
okay, I'm gonna try to draw it like,
right right here, kind of, I hope I get it right, I have um, I have these,
I have these, these are uh fabric markers, so I'm gonna sketch with the fabric marker
and then I will um, I don't have anything to like hold this down, and then I will paint
with paint, with uh, fabric paint, yeah, I got fabric paint, I really enjoy the background music,
I forgot I even had background music,
oh, I do have background music, no pins to hold it, no I don't have pins to hold it, no,
man I'm gonna have to draw a good circle too, maybe I should trace a circle,
I have this, I have this, should I try tracing a circle with this or, or maybe my cup,
hold on, oh that's kind of small,
that's even smaller,
should I try tracing a circle with this, this is kind of dangerous,
I'll try,
okay well that's like, oh you can't even see it, that's like, generally a circle,
it's like the, the general shape of a circle, kind, kind of, right,
damn it, why did my chat disappear, why does it always do this, oh well I guess I won't,
maybe, hold on, I'm using my nose right now, oh god damn it,
okay,
how do I turn my phone on, do not disturb, do not disturb, don't disturb me right now, I'm busy,
I hope you didn't see that text from my cousin that appeared on my screen,
that would be um, that would be breaking your illusion a lot,
is it still, is that still paint thinner, no that's just water,
okay, must be nice to be produced by two other organisms, I was a failed lab experiment,
that was a bandit, I really don't call this a darkness, your students health, thanks for everything,
you're so funny, we couldn't see it, okay good, good, good, good,
there we go, I know I'm always worried that like, I'm gonna, I'm gonna accidentally show like,
I don't know, something crazy like my internet history or my address by using my phone on stream,
okay, um, so I know you can't see it very well, but I, I dotted um, a circle
with my cup, so yeah, and now I have to paint it, wait, um, I got this very fancy,
I literally got this today, I got a very fancy paint brush holder, show the history, no, no,
no I can't, I can't, I can't, I got this very fancy paint brush holder for all my paint brushes,
oh wait, I should actually sketch out the cat too, shouldn't I, frick, oh shit,
man, uh, okay, I see myself in your phone, oh,
what do you mean, oh you mean you see chat, oh yeah, yeah, I have, I have, I do in fact have chat
open on my phone, okay, I'll try to sketch out the cat, so many brushes, I am an artist,
I've kind of collected these over a lot of years and they're all really cheap,
they're not like fancy brushes or anything, um, yeah, it's chat, what kind of paintings do you do,
um, okay, I don't actually really, I don't actually really paint much, um,
I don't really paint much like,
this is more oval, isn't it, I don't really paint much like paint things with actual paint,
I really should, I think I should more, um, do more of that, but um,
I feel like I have the wrong color here, okay, this is the color I need, this one's not dark enough,
but um, I used to do a lot of like watercolor stuff,
yeah, I used to do a lot of watercolors, so a lot of my brushes are like watercolor brushes,
like this shape, um, because that's what I use them for, yeah,
so Bijuu is a master artist, oh, Bob Bijuu is a master artist,
I mean, if you want to think about it like that, sure, I'm Bob Bijuu, oh yeah, I didn't,
I don't have like an artist, should I get like an artist, um, should I get like a, like a, like,
what's it called, some like the hat, a beret, should I get a beret and place it on top of myself,
that's kind of a lot of work, and I'm kind of lazy, I'm just dotting this on, it looks like it tickles,
what, what tickles, the marker, I kind of made it too big, I made her face kind of big, maybe that's
good though, there's no erasing in this, so we just kind of have to do our best,
oh the paintbrush, it doesn't really tickle, I should do some more, I should do, I should
do some peep brush ASMR, I feel like it would sound good, obviously this is my streaming, um,
microphone, so it probably doesn't sound like ASMR, our minimal effort emotol, I put a lot of effort,
just not into every single thing I do, sometimes I need like, sometimes we need low effort days,
okay, you could trace with a pencil then use the marker, nah, that's too much work, I mean I know
what I'm doing is a lot of work, but that's like extra work, you know, and like, we're just trying
to, we're just trying to get it done, we're not, we're not trying to, you know, do anything crazy
now, I feel like I should, I should, I need to hold it like this, maybe I should,
struggling here, I kind of made it, made it, made her a little long, I guess she is kind of long,
your mom is going to wear this around, you need to make sure she looks good,
nah, I mean she'll wear it no matter what it looks like, I uh, I made a shirt for her when
I was in like seventh grade with, with literally like these exact kind of markers, it was such an
ugly shirt, but she wore it for a really long time until it faded, and um, she wore it because I
made it which is cute, but every time I saw it as I got older I was like mom why do you still wear
that shirt, it's so ugly, okay and then a little nose, there we go, I don't know, she's a little bit
widened, I tried, wholesome, it is wholesome, it is cute, it's kind of, I don't know, she's,
she's an interesting, she's a strange person, yeah moms do love that kind of stuff, okay um,
I need paint now, oh I don't have my um, okay hold on, I need to get my, my um, what's it called,
what's it called, palette, paint palette, yeah I need to get that,
the rats are kind of active right now, I kind of want to, I kind of want to get them out, but
there's so much stuff that they could ruin, like I had to get all new fabric paints because they
literally ate my old fabric paints, I think I kind of want to let them out, I'll just, I'll just give
you a rat tour where I'll just show you the rat and then put it back in the cage, rat tour
check, this is Luna,
she doesn't really, none of my rats like being held because they're not really from
breeders, they're just like random rats that I find, but that's Luna,
if you get a rat from a reputable breeder, they should be really friendly, but if you just get
a random rat like I do, they might not be as friendly, but this is Luna
and here's Pixie, yay, she also, oh Pixie, she also doesn't like being held,
but at least she'll let me, come back, okay Pixie just
okay, well Pixie's out, it's okay, and I can't show you Dennis because Dennis bites and she
hates me, oh shit my phone turned off, okay, Pixie was the one who bit your feetsies,
I don't know, was she, she's right over here, you can't see her, but maybe she'll come,
hi Pixie, no she doesn't want to, um here's my shitty palette, it's covered in paint because
I'm a lazy artist, she's a menace, Dennis is a menace, she's camera shy and she's a menace, yeah
and Pixie's trying to steal my toilet, not my toilet paper, but my paper towel, come here,
come back in your face, come back in your face,
very professional, I know, I got it from uh Dolorama, which is the Canadian dollar store,
except they, it's like the Canadian Five Below basically, okay let's start with white,
let's start with white, like rat like owner, both camera shy and menaces, but in a good way,
if I was a rat I'd probably bite too to be honest, I'd probably bite too, oh I got a super chat,
why didn't I see that, sweet cats cartoon logo would look cool to paint, oh swat cats, not sweet
cats, what is swat cats, I've never heard of that, are you gonna make me look up swat
cats with my nose right now, I bet you'd bite, yeah I would bite, yeah I would bite,
it's a 90s cartoon, my mom didn't watch cartoons, and she's also not born in the 90s,
but my mom didn't watch cartoons mostly because she uh, they didn't have, did you see her?
She's scared,
aww, please don't steal that, she didn't have cartoons um
on tv when she was younger, so cute, I'm gonna attack her and put her back in her cage,
come here, where are you going?
okay, she's back in the cage, she didn't actually have cartoons on tv as a kid,
um, not to say that she's that old, it's just like,
you monster,
baby rat prints on shirt, nah, she doesn't really like rats, how am I supposed to open this?
oh, making a huge fucking mess,
there, no paint goes to waste in this house, I hope that's enough,
oh my god, let the rats free, no they're gonna eat the paint, I want this open,
bruh, what am I supposed to do here, this is cardboard on the inside,
uh, they have nothing to poke through,
yeah, one already ate a marker, they're gonna eat the paint, I don't want them to eat my paint,
don't take their freedom away, I already took their freedom away, what the frick, okay, hold on,
I can't use the paintbrush to poke it out, because the paintbrush isn't, um,
oh I almost had it, okay, I got it out, the paintbrush isn't thin enough to poke it out,
pinky won't poke, pinky, how tiny do you think my pinky is, this is the hole,
you can't even see the hole, this is the hole, my pinky will not fit through that hole,
man, I already got paint on me, damn it,
you want me to take your freedom away, your freedom was gone the second you started watching me,
I ate your soul the second you watched me, the second you tuned into my stream and decided wow,
I kind of like imibisu, that's when I took your soul and it's mine now, this is too small,
let's use a bigger one, let's use a bigger one, should I try this one,
yeah there was a ritual and everything, you're right, we did do a ritual, both of us did a ritual,
actually speaking of ritual, I got a, Shibi's doing um, Shibi's doing a, what's it called,
Shibi's doing a spell, a spell, uh, I think she's making spell jars, she's doing a spell jar
making stream, before me, I had to do a spell jar stream, I literally bought all the stuff I need
for spell jars and I never made them because I asked, um, I asked Manesan if I, if I could like
send out the, the spell jars that I make to you guys and I never got a response, so I was like,
I'm not sure if I should do one where like, you customize it to what you like, because
you know, I would want to send it out, I would, I don't care, I would cover the shipping costs, but
I don't know if that's like dangerous to do, you know,
maybe I'll just do a spell jar making stream without sending it out to people,
it would be nice if I could, I trust this with my address, you shouldn't, I'm kidding, um,
no, she didn't take my thing, Shibi's into witchcraft too,
when I first met her, I was like, Shibi, are you into witchcraft?
Because I, I could see from her, um, old, old clips that she did that kind of stuff and she was
like, yeah, are you? And I was like, yeah, it was nice. And Mercy is a little bit too, I think
she's not as into it as the rest of us, I'm not sure, did Mercy do a, did Mercy do a, a tarot,
the stream? I don't remember, I'd say don't send anything that would breed FOMO,
um, maybe you're right, I wouldn't be able to send it to every single viewer when I wouldn't be able to,
I don't know, I thought it like a watery system would be fun,
so that way everyone has a fair chance, but maybe you're right.
Should I do a little foot reveal? Which foot looks better, hold on, this foot looks better,
even closer. So if we cheat, we walk in with no genus tomorrow? What do you mean cheat? Like on me?
You're, you're walking with no genus and no tongue either.
And maybe even no fingers.
The toes, the toes! Also by the way, I know some people get sad when I don't read their,
their chat messages, I do read everything, like I read it in my head, I just, like I,
I see every chat message and I do read it in my head, I don't like it completely ignore,
you know, chat, I do try to pay attention to chat as much as possible, I just can't respond to every
message, you know, so don't ever feel like, oh, she didn't see my message, no bitch, I see everything.
Well, I may not see stuff that mods delete, but like other than that, I see everything.
She doesn't hate us? Why would I hate you? What are you talking about? Yeah, I see everything.
Read this, I read it. She ignores, let's be honest, I don't ignore chat! Bro,
I appreciate chat so much, okay?
Fuck, I'm getting a foot cramp, fuck, fuck, fuck!
Oh my god, hold on, fuck, ah! Oh fuck, ah!
Okay, as I was saying, um,
I appreciate chat so much because I spent the longest time being like a, an average of
fucking five viewers streamer, okay? I spent the longest time averaging like five viewers,
so um, my chat was pretty dead back then, if you can imagine, so having people actually talk to me,
I appreciate it a lot, it's, it makes, thank you for becoming a member.
Yeah, a whole five viewers, my top average actually not, okay, not to flex on you right now,
okay, I don't want to make you feel jealous if you're another streamer, but my highest average
viewers was nine, yep, yep, I was so proud of that too, I was like auditioning to Vtuber companies,
and I was like, I have an average of nine viewers. I was like using that as like my um,
my experience for streaming, I was like, I've streamed for eight months straight consistently,
and I have an average of nine viewers. She was a one viewer, she was one viewer away from 10,
I know, I was so sad, I didn't want to round it up because I knew they could easily look up my average,
and if I lied, then they wouldn't take me, you know. Sign her up now! Where was phase connect?
They should have been up in my DMs trying to get me, I was so famous.
I mean, I hear it's hard to break five, it's hard to break any amount, especially on Twitch,
it's hard to get any amount on Twitch, in general, in general, it's hard to get any amount,
I need more paint, phase connect, yeah, they should have taken me, like, I was, I was, I was
right before the pickin'. They missed out. I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm joking, I'm joking,
that's a joke. Thank you, that's a joke. Imagine nine people just wanting to watch what you're
doing in real life, yeah, and like, two of them were absolutely not my friends that I knew in real
life. Two of them were not people I knew in real life, so yeah, imagine nine people wanting to
watch you, that's like, you know, that's pretty, that's, that's, that's a lot, it is a lot, so yeah.
I had an average of four and was happy about any one more, I was happy too, like, I remember
one of, like, the best, this is kind of cringe, but one of my, like, earlier happy memories during
streaming was, this is so cringe, I got, okay, I would never get rated as the streamer mostly
because I had shit stream quality, so um, one time a streamer rated me with 13 viewers,
I know, one time a streamer rated me with 13 viewers, right, and I got so nervous, and um,
during that stream, this was when I was, like, more starting out, during that stream,
I had an average of seven viewers, and I was, like, hyped, I was, like, looking at the view count,
and I was like, holy shit, seven of them have been staying here, seven of them have stayed here with
me this whole time, and I just thought I was, like, really hyped, because seven of them stayed.
How many viewers did you hit that stream? Um, I don't know, maybe, maybe I had a max of, like,
because when people raid, you know, everyone leaves raid away, basically, so it's not, like,
that crazy, um, people left for sure, but maybe, maybe during that stream, I had, like, a height of,
like, 16, which for me back then was, like, crazy, crazy, but like I said, my stream quality was,
like, shit, it was so bad, it was so shit, like, so shit, um, but now it's a little bit better,
a little bit. Say it's better. It's better now, right? This is good stream quality, right?
Tell me it's good. I know that my camera is very cluttered, but I'm a very cluttered person in my
life, so this is normal for me. I know this whole area is very cluttered, it doesn't look nice,
but that's normal for me, okay? Why can you,
do a dinosaur? No, it's too late, I'm already doing a cat.
Oftentimes being a raid coming from a four to eight hour stream, wait,
I didn't see what, what, you've changed for the better?
Am I missing something? What are you talking about? Hold on, let me scroll up with my nose.
It's good? Good. Good quality, good. My camera might die a couple times because this, I'm using a
fancy camera, which was, like, $600, um, but it overheats, it overheats while I'm streaming,
so it, like, dies randomly. I was rated by a friend with 45 and I cried for a bit,
was fun, but also traumatizing experience. Do you have an Xbox mic? I did not use an Xbox
mic, no. I used, um, I used, like, a wee wee shaped one from Amazon, it was, like, really
phallic shaped, I was really bad. I'd lose my mind if I had seven viewers, my average is, like,
1.1, bro. At that point, that's just a skill issue, I'm not gonna lie, I'm not gonna lie, um,
cock mic. Sorry, I'm trying, I gotta, I gotta stop saying, like,
peepee and stuff on stream because, like, every single one of my streams get, um,
limited ads on YouTube. You can't just do him like that, bro, please don't make this
camera's not $600, please, it was. Sorry, is it that ugly? I think it looks good.
It was $600. My, my darling pin pals have helped me get it. Listen, I'm gonna go over, okay,
I'm gonna go on a rant about streaming. I'm gonna go on a rant about streaming, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, tiny little, fuck, uh-oh, little VTuber thinks she knows how to stream, I don't, but I think,
um,
I think a lot of people, um, can I please, a lot of people try out, oh,
can I have, like, one single, um, fucking hell.
Can I have one single train of thought without it being interrupted by myself?
Um, I think a lot of people start off streaming and, um, don't really know
much about how to stream and then they get discouraged when their average view count is low,
you know? Now, obviously, if you're just doing for, doing it for fun and you don't really care,
that's fine too. Honestly, I'm not gonna lie, don't tell Strani, don't tell Strani I said this,
but I've considered literally making, like, a Minecraft channel where I have, like, nothing,
like, not even a VTuber model and I just stream Minecraft, no one. I've been considering doing
that. I'm not gonna tell, I'm not gonna tell any of you. One day you'll, you'll come across a stream
on Twitch and there'll be a shitty Minecraft stream and there's gonna be no Facecam, no
nothing, no, no PNGTuber, nothing and it's just gonna be me streaming Minecraft and no one.
And you're gonna be like, her voice sounds familiar but I just, I can't quite pinpoint who this could
be. But anyways, um, I've completely forgot what I was gonna say to be honest. Yeah,
if you're doing it for fun, who cares, is fine, but I think some people get a little bit, oops,
no sorry, oh, ill my hair. Oh my god, is this red hair or is it pink hair? I went, I had, I used
to have pink hair for a long time but this might be red hair from the wig I used to make hair,
hair petting ASMR. Um, where was I going on this rant? Where was I going in general? That's too small.
That's too small. Um, honestly I don't quite remember what I was saying.
I don't quite remember what I was saying. Something about streaming. Um, that was a little hard.
Okay, there we go.
I don't think I have ADHD. I don't think I do. I probably have something though for sure,
but I don't think it's ADHD. Something's wrong. I remember when I was having issues, I was having,
let's not get too deep into it, I was having mental health issues in seventh grade is when it
started in seventh grade, specifically at my best friend's sleepover. Um, and I stayed up like all
night that night because I was freaking the fuck out and they, my mother refused to bring me home
because she was sleeping and the, the, my friend's parents refused to bring me home too because they
were sleeping and I was just freaking out all night and my friend was like tired and I was like,
please stay up with me, please stay up with me. I can't, I can't be up alone and she was like,
I mean, I'm fucking going to sleep on tired. But um, I went to the doctor, right? And the doctor was
like, does your family have a history of um, mental health issues at all? And my mom was like,
no. She was like, no, I don't think so. No, no, no, not that I remember, right?
Bitch, I don't know why she's thought no because when I went to visit my family,
and you know how parents drop like dad lore and mom lore, you know how parents like randomly drop
lore? She did that to me when we were visiting our family and she was like, did you know that
actually when I was a kid, my mom has three, uh, two siblings. Oh, shit, camera. How long was that
going? Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Oh, fuck. I fucked it up again. Hold on. Hold on, hold on, hold on. I, uh, sorry.
Um, video capture device. Turn that off. Okay. Let me try this again. Sorry.
Can I go back? I actually, I don't know how to use this camera.
Amy got a stand. What do you mean a stand?
What? What do you mean the world though? Only a minute of true? Like two minutes?
Damn it, since the start of the rant, fucking hell.
Um, live streaming. Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, shit. No.
There we go. Oh, and I'm getting it. I'm getting it. Hold on.
Okay. Okay.
I literally just told you this camera, um, this camera freezes from overheating.
Um.
Sorry, I'm eating my mic. Okay, I think this should be good.
We're back. We're back. Anyways, as I was saying,
what model camera is it? A Sony ZV-1F. That one. I mean, you can see my legs.
Let me pull this in more towards me. Oh, fuck. I got pain on the shirt somewhere.
I can really forget what I was talking about. Right. I was visiting, um, my family with her.
Well, her family. I'm not that close to them, um, but we were visiting her family slash my family.
Um, and she was like, did you know that when I was a kid, she dropped some mom more. She was like,
when I was a kid, right? My, um, my mom, uh, so your grandma actually like had a little bit of a
mental breakdown and she had to go to the mental hospital for like a month and my dad had to take
care of us. Your grandpa had to take care of us all alone. And I was like, what? What? And you never
told me this? And she was like, yeah, yeah. And then she just talked more about like her dad taking
care of her and her siblings. And, um, what was I even talking about? And, um, I met my uncle
and my cousins and I was talking to my cousins and my cousin was like, yeah,
our dad like has serious anxiety issues. Like he has really bad anxiety. He doesn't really admit
it that much. Sometimes he does, but he has, he's really, um, he's really anxious about everything.
And I was like, wow, I must run in the family, huh? I guess, I guess our family does have a history.
No history of mental illness at all. Amy's scatterbrained. Yeah, I'm always scatterbrained.
Your grandma was joker? No, my grandma was in joker. No. I don't know. How do I,
I gotta, hold on. Let me, um,
settings. Hold on. I'm changing it so my phone doesn't turn off after like five minutes with my nose.
Uh, display.
There it is. Screen time out. Wait, I can't, I can't make it never.
Wow. Oh, thank you for the five gifted. Yogi, thank you. I can't make it never.
That's so mine.
Hold on. Let me mute that. Oh, it is muted already. Never mind.
Yay, thank you for the gifted. That's so kind of you. Thank you.
I found that some parents are against mentioning mental health issues in the family. It definitely
doesn't help when you're trying to get help. It really doesn't. It really doesn't. Yeah.
Yeah. Sorry, I didn't have text to speech on. Um, I think,
I think I could turn it on now though.
Okay, now text to speech should be on.
Okay.
Came back from the making the Emmy card to be greeted by a gifted Emmy card. What Emmy card? A
card for me? You could turn off screen sleep for when it's charging, but you have to go into
developer settings. Uh, I ain't no developer. I don't know how to do that. I'll just keep using my nose.
Okay, now we can do black.
I think it's a partly culture thing. I think it's our family. I was talking to my cousin and I was
like, is this a cultural thing? And she was like, no, no, no, most other parents I've met are not
like our family. I think it's an, it's an our family thing. Did I open this? I did not.
Both my parents were doctors and there's a really strong history of mental illness on
both sides of the family, but still it still took till I was in my twenties before I got diagnosed
with anxiety. Yeah. Yeah. I think some parents are a little bit in denial about it. And my mom is
really, really anxious too. My mom's got other issues too. Um, but she's like mega in denial. Like
she will not. Okay, sorry. I'm just hearing a really loud motorcycle. She will not
admit to anything at all. She will not admit to anything. And I'll tell her like, mom, I think
you have some, I think you might have some issues and she'll be like, no, I'm fine. I'm fine. I don't
know what you're talking about. No, me. No, no, no, no.
Send to you a tweet with some ways to help with the overheating. Oh, thank you.
I'll try checking in, checking it out later. I don't know why it does that. I can't open this.
I can open it. I just need to take off the glove. That's all.
She's in denial. Denial is a river in Egypt. Your husband is gay.
It's probably a generation thing. Older people generally don't like acknowledging mental illness
at all as they consider it somewhat, something shameful. That's true too. That's true too.
But I think my mom genuinely doesn't think anything's wrong with her.
Like my uncle, my cousin said my uncle does admit to a little bit of something wrong with him.
Like he has a little bit of issues, but my mom straight up just doesn't admit to anything.
Where did I put this? Oh, there. And then I have to open this one.
Every time I see, um, oh, I thought it was positive. Every time I see you rating my burps in chat,
I'm always surprised because I always forget that I burped.
Let me, um, try opening this now.
I just like, I just, I like just ignoring my issues. I do the same thing.
Okay, I'm going to, come on. Open, please. Please.
Come on. I'm trying not to splatter it everywhere. Come on.
Okay. Ah!
I hope that'll work.
Oh, I'm fucking stupid. Damn it.
Am I late on chat? Question is, no, I'm not late on chat. Oh, you bitch. You dumb whore. Oh, man.
Now these gloves are going to be like that forever.
I want to help you so bad. Oh, please come help me. I'm so helpless and weak. Please, please.
Can anyone count their issues on one hand?
I think I could. I might, I might use up the whole hand, but I think I could.
Okay. There.
Mmm. That's too big. Didn't I have another brush around here?
Oh, here's another one. Well, that's too small.
Maybe I can use this one. Sorry if you hear noise. It's my, my headphone wire hitting the mic.
Um, I was so zoned in on watching all that happening with the paint. That what?
Okay, that's really fucking annoying. Please be normal for like two seconds.
Can I not have a scuff scream for, scream for two seconds?
I was going to rant about something else too, but I forgot what it was. Oh yeah, the streamer thing.
Okay, I actually am a little bit passionate about this. Um,
one time I actually had a friend that got rated because this friend was like really,
really popular. Not popular. This friend had a lot of other friends and so their friends were
like popular and sometimes would rate them and they would get rated with like 300 viewers and
I'd be like, damn, that's crazy. Imagine getting rated with 300 viewers. I would freak out.
I love your scuff.
I think, I think streamers in general are kind of just, um, destined to be scuffed, you know.
Technology is hard and also, um, things go wrong a lot.
Listen, don't say the amount of viewers. Stop it. I'm trying not to look at that.
Ever since I left Twitch, I can't turn off the viewer count. I don't know how. I'm trying not to
look at it. Um, oh yeah, right. Okay, so I was talking about the streamer thing. So I think a
lot of people get discouraged when their, uh, when their view count is low. If they're, if they're
trying to take streaming like seriously, you know, if they're trying to take stream seriously, then
they might get discouraged because it's like, oh, you know, I'm, I'm streaming, but I have so little
viewers. What's going on? What's wrong? I'll tell you what's wrong. You suck. Skill issue.
Quit. Die. Give up. Turn the stream off and leave forever. Um, that's not true.
Okay, there could be a lot of things wrong, but some, some really big issues that I notice
is because I'm a small streamer connoisseur. I actually only watch small streamers. I don't
watch big streamers. Name any big VTuber. I don't watch them. Um, name any small VTuber. I also
don't watch them because there's a lot of small VTubers and I don't watch that many VTubers in
general. Um, but don't listen to these, don't listen to these other people in me. I'm your only
viewer. I'm only streaming to one person right now and that's my big brother. Um,
but a really big problem I've noticed, especially, I'm gonna kill myself. It blended in with the
white in Minecraft, especially amongst the ones that are like, you know, kind of disappointed
that they don't have that many viewers is that they don't talk like they'll play the game and then
they won't talk. And, um, I've had people tell me like, oh, the only reason you're getting, um,
more viewers is because you're a girl. And this is when I had like average of like nine viewers,
you know, they'd be like, because you're a girl and it's like, listen, I am, I was pretty cute back
then, back then. Um, but I put a lot of effort into my streams. Even though they were scuffed,
I still put a lot of effort into them. I put whatever effort I could and also I fucking talked.
I was a yapper. I did, I did gaming week where I streamed for like every day playing video games
every day. Um, I really burned myself out of streaming, but I non stopped yapped during those
gaming streams. I was a yapper and that's the only reason I even had a little bit of viewers,
despite my stream being so scuffed is because I kept yapping and I was actually pretty funny.
And I was, I was a cute girl. I'm not going to lie. I was cute, but I wasn't cute enough to the point
where like, I wasn't cute enough to the, what? Why does she look like that? She looks normal to me.
I don't know. I wasn't cute enough to the point where my, um, cuteness could like, you know how
there's like booby streamers, like titty streamers and like a lot of people are like, oh, they only
have viewers because their titties are out, you know? Um, can you feel the gap on the ear?
Which gap? Which gap?
Playing games? Who are you and what have you done with Amy? I normally didn't play games. That's
why I had gaming week. That's, that's why I had gaming week where, where I would play games.
Because I normally did not play any games. Um, but that was my gaming week where I would play
games. God damn, this is really annoying. Okay, hopefully that'll stop it.
And maybe where the black has hit the white and made it gray. Yeah, I'll fix that, don't worry.
I'll fix any shitty mistakes. Okay, well, I'll try, I'll try to fix any shitty mistakes.
I'll try, okay? But like, I, I, uh, I only have so much energy I can put towards this,
this kind of shitty drawing of a cat. Um, I also did not show my titties on stream either.
Um, so I feel like the fact that it was, that sometimes I would be told like, oh, you're a girl,
so that's why you get straight, that's why you give yours. I wasn't showing my boobies,
like ever. That was the, the, when I showed my boobies here was the first time I've ever
showed my boobies on stream. So like, you know, I wasn't, um, I was not getting viewers because
I was a girl. I was just getting viewers because I was yapping and I was trying to be entertaining.
If you weren't, then that makes you a better streamer. No, no, I'm not gonna shit on booby
streamers. Oh fuck it, paused again. Okay.
Why does it do that? Should I switch cameras? Should I switch cameras?
Rade? Oh, harem raid. Hi. We are not experiencing technical difficulties right now.
There we go.
Hi, harem. Hi, sheeby. What was sheeby doing? I don't even remember. Hello.
Do you use the camera with the screen out? No. I don't know. The, the screen out? No,
I'm not looking like, I don't have the screen, the screen flipped open or anything. I'm not looking
at it. Sucker for love. Oh, I heard of that. Is it a dating simulator? I heard it was a dating
simulator. I think it's a dating simulator. I feel those streamers aren't the best and
not as much entertaining other than the things, other than the other things making them entertaining.
I don't know. How you sound, how you sounded.
Man, I'm having a seizure. Not a seizure. I'm having a strong, um,
um, well obviously some of them, some booby streamers just kind of like,
you know, um, the point of the streamers, they're boobies, but some streamers just have their
boobies out and sometimes they may have their boobies out, but they could also be entertaining
with their boobies out. You know, having your boobies out doesn't make you not entertaining,
you know? Or you try to, or you try to seduce goat goddess mommy girl. Oh, goat goddess.
Oh, goat goddess. Like, Azura? Um, this is kind of bad. Should I make like a white outline?
Not a white outline, a black outline.
I think I need to make the eyes bigger.
It was Azura's eldritch twin.
Um, so yeah, my biggest advice is to yap and then my second biggest advice
is to post other content. Don't just stream. Don't just stream. Maybe back in the day when
streaming was still kind of new, you could just only stream and maybe get popular,
but nowadays there's so many streamers that you have to post other content to,
you know, make your chances bigger. Like, I've seen streamers not post other content that much
and still get pretty big, but um, I, I don't, I don't hit lotteries like that.
We don't, we don't, not around here partner, not around here. We don't, we don't get lucky
like that. We got to post other content, you know? And it doesn't have to be like, I don't know.
It doesn't have to be like full length YouTube videos. It can just be clips as long as they're
entertaining. Some people get labeled as city streamer. They aren't even sexual. They just
happen to have boobs. Yeah. Some people, like, I don't know, girls can be comfortable and have
their boobies out and that's okay. They don't have to be a city streamer just because they have
the boobies out, you know? Trying to make the eyes bigger. That's better.
There we go. And the nose. And then I need to make the whiskers, but I think I'm going to go
one more time around, um, yeah, I'm going to go around the circle one more time just to make it
like, um, it's not positive. Just to make it, um, I'm getting a knee cramp now.
Just to make it a little more opaque. Hold on. I got to stretch out my knees.
I got bad knees. I don't know why I got bad knees, but I got bad knees.
Ah.
Okay. Oh, I gotta do this, like, too, I think.
Yeah, that's my rant about streamers. I'm still salty to this day because, uh,
someone said I only get viewers because I'm a girl, even though I had, like, nine viewers.
And I would be like, dude, just talk, just talk, just, just yap a little bit. I know playing the
game is fun. I know you have fun playing the game. If I hear one more fucking bump, I'm going to kill
my soul in Minecraft. I'm going to jump off the Minecraft. I'm trying to think of a way to end
my life in Minecraft. I'm going to jump in lava.
Okay, I hope that works. Can you see the wire? No, I think I'm covering it, which is good.
Nine viewers is a luxury to some people it is. To me, it was. I was really proud of it.
I was super proud of myself back then for nine because those nine people were there for me.
And now you're here for me too, which makes me very happy.
Um, and I'm not as nervous anymore too when there's a lot of people watching, you know.
I'm not as nervous anymore. Like, when we're gonna debut, I was a little bit nervous.
Um, like right before debut, I was a little bit nervous. I was like, oh, it's starting to hit.
It's starting to hit. I'm getting a little nervous because I knew there was going to be
quite a few people because, you know, you know, we did the Sponsored Watch Alongs.
And, you know, we got a read from DTL. So I knew there was going to be like quite a few people,
but I wasn't sure how many. And there was quite a few people still. And I was a little nervous,
but once I actually like got into the groove of things, I was pretty okay. I wasn't like shaking.
I wasn't shaking. I wasn't, I was sweaty because it was hot outside, but like,
other than that, I was mostly okay, which I'm proud of myself. I've gone, I've come, I've come so far.
Wow, wow. Thank you for becoming a member. I've come so far.
We're proud of you for no longer being nervous. Oh, thank you.
Yes, it is also good to have a group of fellow streamers. I was instantly hooked.
I almost ate the paint water.
Okay, we're almost done.
I got groomed. It wasn't my choice at all. It is your choice when you get groomed.
It's all your fault for getting groomed.
All your fault.
That was all I had to say about the streamer thing.
Some people also think that streaming long hours makes you more popular,
which is a bad idea because I thought the same thing, not more popular, but that you would grow
an audience better. I thought the same thing. I was like, I should stream longer because then I have,
you know, more chance of getting more viewers. So I streamed for like four hours.
I streamed for like four hours. Oh, fuck it. Pause.
Okay. Oh my God. I'm just scaring the shit out of me.
Hi, Emmy. Love your ASMR first time being able to catch a stream. Thanks for being awesome.
Oh, thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Double Emmy. Yeah, sorry. I have to switch. I have to like refresh the...
Please, please, please, please. How do I do this?
Now you can see the wire though. Sorry.
When life's pause button works.
It's, it's, I don't know how to use cameras. I got one, I got one because I knew I was going
to do a lot of hand cam streams. So I wanted to get a good camera, but now I'm struggling
because I don't know how to use cameras. So my camera's overheating.
Anyways, that's the white part.
I look your Twitter first when I was checking viewer before your debut. Then I found your teasing
audio. By God, I couldn't escape. My teasing audio? What's teasing audio?
My teasing audio? Man, I don't even know my own audios.
Wait, you stream? I think I do. Sometimes. Yeah, I did it for like four hours back then,
and I was always so tired afterwards and I was like, fuck man, four hours, four hour shift.
Four hour shift talking to nobody. Talking to myself. Jildo? What? Oh, I did,
I did do some teasing. I think I, I put out like a couple of audios on Twitter before that. Yeah.
I need to listen to the ASMR at some point. You should, but I really don't have that much out.
It puts again? What the fuck? Okay, I think I need to switch cameras. I'm sorry. Now it's getting
really bad. Okay, I'm going to switch cameras. I'm going to switch to one that doesn't overheat.
It is lower quality, but what can you do? Okay, hold on. Give me a second. Here,
I'll put on the BRB screen so you don't have to deal with me struggling. Hold on.
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, damn it.
Now, I've been noticing any comments saying,
Amy, is this a different camera? I don't notice the difference. Yes, it is. It is a different
camera and you better notice the difference. But yeah, this is a different camera. I swear
to God, if people are like, oh, is this a different camera? Please, please, please, please.
I do see the difference. Thank you. This one's obviously lower quality, right?
Very different. Okay. It looks the same. Stop. Stop.
The t-shirt looks smoother because this is a lower quality camera.
That's why the t-shirt looks smoother.
The quality is being, you know, it's smoothing it out, you know? It's blurrier. Yeah. Yeah.
Right? I don't know. It's good enough for now. Is this a different shirt? No, no.
Couldn't tell it was a cat until now. Stop. Now you're just, now you're just
jor-jorking my peanuts now. Now you're just jor-jorking my peanuts. You're pulling on it.
Can you hear me good? Okay, good. Is this a different emotional? It's the same one.
It's the same one. Can you see all the wrinkles now? What wrinkles? Oh, shit.
What wrinkles are you talking about?
It is the cat from Kiki's delivery service. I think that's what it's supposed to be, at least.
It's a little bit gloopy. The paint's a little bit gloopy.
It's Gigi, the male cat. Uh-oh, male on stream. Oh, no. Oh, no.
It's okay. It's just a kitty.
We have X-ray vision. Does that mean you can see through my gloves?
Does that mean you can see through my pants?
There we go.
There we go. It's so cute. Okay, I'm gonna clean the edges of the cat too now.
We can see all the hair.
I'm not covering it because I didn't shave or anything.
That's not why.
Oops, I had more.
Sorry, I gotta stretch my back out. Oh my god. Can you stretch my back out for me?
Uh, it hurts. I hate aging. I know, I'm sorry. I'm acting like I'm 40 years old.
I'm sorry to any real 40-year-olds out there.
Hi, glove.
I don't, every time, when I was a kid, I would always kind of tease my mom for being old because
she actually used to lie to me about her age. She would always tell me she's younger than she is.
And I started teasing her for her age because she would, you know, lie about it to me.
And now it's like, fuck, man, I don't like being teased for my age.
Don't tell me I'm a hag. It offends me.
Yeah, it means only 38.
Stop. I'm not 38.
My mom was 36 for about five years. That's what I'm saying. My mom would do the same thing.
It was her birthday recently and I was like, mom, how old are you turning? And she was like,
you don't know. And I guessed. And then I guess I guessed an, um,
I guessed an age too low, like by one year and she got all offended. She was like,
no, do I really look that age? And it's like, mom, you've been sun tanning for like 10 years of
your life. You unfortunately do look that age. Unfortunately, mom, you do look that age because
you've been sun tanning so much. And now she understands that sun tanning is bad for her skin.
When she was younger. Oh my God. I had to wait, I had to wait hours at the sun tanning salon
because she loved sun tanning. I remember one time I went on a school trip and I guess it was summer
and, um, it was for like a week. And then when I finally got back, she came to pick me up
from school and I didn't even recognize her because she was so orange. It was like a jumpscare
when I saw her face. I was like, whoa, whoa, what happened to you? And she's like, I was just
tanning a little bit in the backyard. She was so orange. She was so orange. And now my cousin
does the same thing except my cousin. My cousin knows that the sun is bad for you. So instead of,
like the Lorax, bro, she was, she was orange than the Lorax. She was so orange.
Except my cousin knows the dangers of the sun. So she uses fake tan. But I feel like low-key,
like fake tan makes you even more orange than regular tanning. And so anytime I see my cousin,
I'm always like, girl, you are so orange. It's giving oompa oompa. But I don't tell her that
because she's really self-conscious about being pale. I don't know why. I don't know why people
are self-conscious about being pale. I think, I really don't think, like, I feel like people's
natural skin tone complement them the most, if that makes sense. Like, I feel like that
complements you the most. And I feel like when you change it, it just looks weird. It looks off.
And hers does complement her. Like, she's, she's really pretty. Like, she's very like,
bro, I'm the fucking ugliest duck in the family. Both of my cousins are like model-esque.
And she's really tall too. But like, she's like, every time we take a photo together, she's like,
oh my god, I look like a dead corpse. And it's like, girl, you just, you're just pale. It's okay.
It's okay to be pale. It's okay. It's not, it's not that big of a deal. You look fine.
She's just a girl. True. True. True. She, she's just a girl. That's hashtag just
girly things. Girls are kind of insecure about silly things, aren't they?
My skin is less pale and more like see-through. See, that's what she says too. She's like,
oh my god, look at me. You can see my fangs. I look like a zombie. And it's like,
that's normal for pale skin. But you can see my veins too. And that's because I have varicose veins.
Sorry, girl. Like, the rest of the family, we're gonna, we're all gonna have very
visible veins at some point.
And yeah, zombies are green. Okay, zombies are green. They're greener or like blue or like,
um, I don't know, like brown, like zombies are like dead colored. Gray even, like, you know.
Is varicose, fancy talk? We're super cute. No, I think, I think varicose is like, um,
oh man, like back. Slouching like a shrimp. Varicose means, um,
uh, I don't even know if that's the right term. Is that the right term? It's like, um,
it's like we can, when you can see the veins really, really clearly, um, despite, I don't know,
it's like a, it's like a, um, it's like a condition, I think. It's like a condition.
My grandma has it really bad because she's old. Yeah, it's when they pop out a bit.
My grandma has it really bad. You can see like all the veins on her leg. My mom,
my mom also has it. It's not as bad as my grandma, but it's, it's very apparent. Um,
and I am developing it as well. Oh, fuck. She got some snot on her.
My mom has spider veins, spider veins? No, varicose veins. I hate when they pop out.
They don't really pop out. Uh, not for me at least. They don't pop out. They just, um,
they're just very, very obvious. Like, um, they're very visible. Um, they don't necessarily pop out
for me or my grandma or anything. I think my grandma may be a little bit because she's like
old, old, but like, for me, they don't pop out and for my mom, they don't pop out. They're just visible.
So the cat's a girl now? I don't know. Is it? Why would it be a girl suddenly? What do you mean?
I thought that's a small mouth. No, that's the nose. This is the little nose.
Oh, did I call, did I call the cat a she? It's a cat. Cats don't care about pronouns. It's a cat.
It's a cat.
You think crow's feet is ugly? I don't know what crow's feet is. What is crow's feet?
Oh, you said she had snot yet. It's a cat. Varicose veins are a bit of a deal later in life,
since it's easier to bruise and stuff, I think. Probably, uh, that makes sense for sure. Um,
but for now, it's not a, not a big deal for me.
Oh, my mom has spider veins. May not be the same thing. I don't know what spider veins is either.
Oh, crow's feet are eye wrinkles. Oh, I don't care.
I have really, really bad wrinkles under my eyes. I've had them since I was a kid, like
they're just naturally there, whether I smile or do anything. I just have like, um,
like, I don't know how to describe it, like, like folds under my eyes kind of,
but like multiple, I have like two under each eye, maybe even three. I think it's just two, actually.
Um, I've had it since I was like a kid.
Yeah, it just means you smile a lot. Yeah, there you go. Eyebags? I don't, I don't, I don't think
it's eyebags. It's like folds. I do have really bad eyebags too. I, I got really bad eyebags too,
but it's like folds, like skin folds. It's not, it's not eyebags. At least I don't think so.
Oh man, it's blending again.
One on one side, two on the other. Yeah. Yeah, eye wrinkles are just a sign that someone smiles a lot. Yeah.
Can you pull a domain expansion? Do you stand on business? I don't even know what that means.
I've, I don't, I don't watch Jiu-Jitsu Kaisen. I don't know what that means.
I bet I could pull a domain expansion if I tried hard enough.
No, eyebags just crazy dark circles. I have dark circles too, yeah. Like someone said,
a natural, a natural eye shadow. I have to, I, whenever I like put makeup under my eyes to
cover my eyebags, I have to put it all around so that it doesn't look like I'm wearing eye shadow
because my, um, my eyebags go like on top of my eyelid too. Oh man, I'm getting in other places too.
And I don't know if it's just a case of not sleeping enough,
because I did wake up really early for school every day.
Um, sorry, not for school. I woke up for daycare every day because my mom would have work at,
I don't know, I think maybe she started at like 7am or something like that,
or maybe like 6.30 or something. She would start really early every morning and, um,
so she would have to take me to daycare every morning and, um,
I would wake up at like 5am every day for like a lot of my childhood just to go to daycare,
which fucking sucked. I hated daycare. I hated daycare because I was the first one there and
the last one to leave, and I hated that. I had my eyebags for 12 years, I think they never went
away. Yeah, sometimes they're just, um, like, like, uh, hyperpigmentation, like they're, uh, genetic.
Yeah, some people just naturally have them.
My IRL sister! I'm your IRL sister!
Uh, looks like she's running on two hours, even when she's fully rested. Yep, that's me.
Growing up, my house was the daycare? Wait, what does that mean? Does that mean your
parents ran a daycare? I need to hide these dots here.
There's like dots down here, and I feel like I need to hide them.
Does the finish, does the finishing product of the cat have no pupils because it's blind?
No! I'm not done yet! It has no pupils because I'm not done yet!
What do you mean? No pupils. There is pupils in the image.
I'm just trying to cover up these dots at the bottom, from the marker.
Some people have never seen Kiki's delivery service. That's okay. I don't know. Where, uh, I mean,
actually, no, that's weird. If you're, if you're like, VTubers in anime, if you, and you've never
watched, like, Ghibli movies, that's weird. But in general, that's normal for some people not
having seen Kiki's delivery service. Because, oh fuck.
A lot of people don't know about anime. I'm gonna kill him. I'm not gonna kill him. I'm not going to do it. Sorry.
It's required viewing. I feel like just, like, a lot of, a lot of, uh, a lot of Studio Ghibli movies
are required viewing if you're an anime fan. Because it's like, it's like the classic, you know?
I don't like it when people are like, oh, you're an anime fan, but you've never seen blah, blah,
blah, blah. Like, I don't like that, but I feel like Studio Ghibli movies are like,
I don't know. They're movies for, like, everyone. So that's, that's fine, you know? But I don't like it
when people are like, oh, you like anime, but you've never watched. Bingo bongo's big adventure z.
You know? I don't like that. I think that's cringe. But yeah.
I mean, I need to not say anything. So my, uh,
I need to not say anything so my streams don't get demonetized. Also, Amy says KMS three times in
one stream. I'm bad at controlling myself. You're bound to run into and watch a Ghibli
movie at some point in your anime career. I watched Ghibli movies before I even knew what anime was.
Like, they were playing at the cinemas here and I would go with my mom and I would watch them.
And even at the library, I, we used to rent out movies from the library and from Blockbuster
too. Yup, yup. I was alive when Blockbuster, Blockbuster is not that old, but from Blockbuster
too, I would rent movies and sometimes I would just rent out like Ghibli movies and I didn't
know that they were anime. I just thought they were cartoons. Like it's pretty, it's, it's, it's
pretty widespread. You miss Blockbuster? I miss Blockbuster too. I miss Blockbuster. Now the only
place to rent movies is the library and like, I don't even know if, I don't, the library, like,
I'm not gonna fucking get on a bus to go all the way to the library to rent a movie, you know?
Casual doxxed age? Not really. Not really.
Blockbuster's pretty new still. Like, it wasn't, I think it, it, maybe the last Blockbuster close
in like what, 2010 maybe? Or like 2015? I don't know. Maybe 2010. When someone, someone look up
on the last Blockbuster close. It was, it really wasn't that long ago. We sail pirate ships these
days. I know and it's nowhere near as comfy to sail a pirate ship. Okay, I'm gonna draw the eyes now,
like the pupils. Like it's, it's nowhere near as comfy to do that, if you ask me.
Like, I don't know. I really need to, to get myself a DVD player because that's just so much
comfier. I don't know why either. I really don't know. Like, something, maybe I do have GERD.
Something about like physically inserting a CD into a DVD player or a DVD. I don't fucking know.
Okay, I don't know the, I don't know the difference. It doesn't matter. Something about physically
inserting a DVD into a DVD player just makes it like 10 times more comfy than like opening
Netflix and like putting on Shrek 3, you know? And I don't know what it is. I really don't.
Um, but yeah. And so I really want to, I think I made the people too big.
Oops. I really want to, um, I really want to get a DVD player. Physical media is the way to go. I know.
It's a comfort ritual. It is. It is. I think the whole experience of just going to Blockbuster
and picking out what you wanted to watch was peak. It was peak. Now I kind of want to watch
Shrek the 3rd. But I wanted to record a Twitter audio after stream. I don't know. I'm so freaking.
I'm tired, grandpa. I'm tired, but like, my cousin said this and I really resonated with it. She was
like, I was born tired. I was born anxious and tired and I was like, oh, same girl. Same.
Hey, you watching Shrek the 3rd? I'll watch any Shrek. I really like the Shrek movies.
The Shrek movies were comfort movies to me as a kid. I really like them.
Yeah.
Because when I would visit my dad's house, there was like, oh, shit. One of the pupils is like
longer than the other. There was like nothing to do at my dad's house because it's like,
it's dad's house, you know? All your shit is at mom's house. There's nothing to do at dad's house.
But when I would visit my dad, actually, I think they're like, you know, it adds to the character,
it adds to the cuteness. But like, I had a TV at my dad's house, so I would sometimes bring CDs and
watch Shrek. Born to sleep, forced to be awake. Born to shit, forced to wipe.
Dad lore. I don't have much dad lore. Um, I don't know. I forced my dad to buy me rats. Okay,
I didn't force my dad to buy me rats. But when I was first getting rats, I was like,
my dad wanted to hang out with me. And so he texted me and he was like, hey, do you want to,
I feel like sometimes he like gets, goes through phases where he feels bad for being an absent
parent. So back then I would answer his texts. And I'd be like, he wants, he texts me and he
was like, hey, can we like, are you free today? Like, you know, we can do something together. And
I was like, sure, I need to ride to, I need to ride, I need to ride to go pick up a pet. And he was
like, yeah, okay, I'll drive you. And um, we went and I picked up rats. And he was like, what are
they? And I was like, rats. And he was like, Oh, yeah. Well, then he looked at them and he
were like, they're kind of cute, I guess. And then I, we went to go pick up like, oh, and he paid
for them. He paid for them. Because like, like I said, he sometimes I feel like he goes through
phases where he feels bad. So he paid for them. And then I was like, Oh, actually, dad, I need to go
get some. Oh, actually, dad, I need to go get some, you know, some stuff for my rats. So we went to
PetSmart. And then he, and then I realized he was going to pay for everything. So I like,
filled up the cart like a lot. I filled up the cart a lot. And he paid for everything. And I was
like, Hey, dad, I actually, I actually need to go get a cage to it. So it's, can we go get that too?
And he was like, Okay. And then I made him paid for the cage. And then I didn't see him for like
another couple more years. So yeah, that's that's how I got um, that's the story of how I got rats.
My dad got them for me. Because, you know, probably because he feels bad, as he should feel bad.
Oh, that one's too long. And it was an expensive trip. It was like, I don't want to say $600, but like,
rats are expensive. Okay, rats are really expensive. Okay, I think that's good.
Um, I think I feel like I should make the ears a little thicker.
Good girl. Real. I am a good girl. Ready sis?
Now you have big brother to buy you things. That's true. Will you buy me more rats? I think,
um, I think I'll make the the ears a little bit thicker, just a little bit.
And a little bit pointier too, because the cat has like really big ears, and that's what makes it really cute.
She's going to end up with 100 rats. No, I'm kidding. I know it's sad, but I don't know. I'm
I'm not quite sure if I'll get more rats. I every time I always say that I always say that I'm like,
no, I don't think I should get more rats. And then I end up getting more rats and um,
it's kind of an addiction, but it's like, it's just so painful losing them, because they're so,
they're so, they're so filled with personality, and um, they live so short, kind of like a VTuber.
They kind of, it's kind of like a VTuber, you know, they're so filled with personality,
and you fall in love with them, and then they graduate, and um, after two years,
yeah, and then they graduate after like two years, and it's like, damn, man.
Rats are the same way, except instead of graduating, they fucking die.
Sometimes if you're lucky, you can get a three years out of one, but you got to be lucky.
Cease.
Emmy, please don't for shadow. I'm not saying I'll graduate after two years.
I'm just saying that's just how VTubers are a lot of the times. Um, but you know, I've been,
I've been streaming on and off since like the second year of college, so I've been streaming for
a long time, and I don't, I don't know, I don't intend on leaving. When you leave me first,
then I'll leave. How about that? You have to leave me first, okay? And then I'll go too. We'll just
die together. No. Talk to author slash YouTuber Jay Ishiro Finney, something, some, some, some time
about rats. He has many. I've had many too. I don't know. It's always painful.
You're stuck here. Deal no take backsies. If Emmy Beezer has zero fans, I'm dead.
There. When you leave, I'll leave too. We both leave together. But yeah, like, I, I always say,
oh, I can't do it. I can't get more rats. And then I end up getting more rats.
Because I always, I don't know, it's kind of my fault too, that they kind of die early, not because
I take bad care of them. But when I get a rat, like I said earlier, I don't, I don't go to a breeder.
I'm just not that kind of bitch. Because breeders will, like, charge like $40 per rat. And I always
get my rats in pairs, because I feel bad like taking them away from their friends. So I get
them in pairs. And it's like, I'm not paying $80 for rats. Hey, I can go in the trash and find a
rat for free, you know? So I always just like go on the Canadian version of Craigslist and find
whoever's giving away like feeder rats or like accident babies rats. And I just get those ones,
you know? And I know that's bad, because those are the rats that will die first.
Kind of like Esteban, you know, that's kind of, that's, that was basically Esteban. She,
she was a feeder rat. So those, those are the ones that are not going to be healthy.
And they will die very quickly from health issues, because they weren't really bred to live.
They were bred to be eaten by snakes and shit. So yeah, it means just, just go searching in the
trash. I will. I will. That's where I'll find my next rat. At least you're giving them a good life.
I am, but it's painful for me. It's painful for me. And sometimes I need to limit myself,
which is really hard because I don't like doing that. I want all the rats.
Is that thick enough?
I think it's thick enough, but I think I need to round the tops a little more.
Careful with the bites. I know, I know, I've been bitten. The, the, the feeders tend to bite too.
They tend to bite, because they're not used to human interaction. But sometimes they'll get used
to you and they'll stop biting. And sometimes they won't. It really just depends on the rat.
Risks are like that. They deserve good lives, but they will bring you heartbreak that much sooner.
Man, I'm getting sad.
Oh, thank you for the two dollars. Gotta bounce. I'll watch the rest in VOD. Okay, bye-bye.
Does a rat can count as nine rats or one giant rat on checkout? I think it counts as nine rats.
They'll get all the money they can from you, at least at the pet store. They will get all the money
they can. Bronx rat? What's Bronx rat? Why are they called feeder? Because they're bred to be fed
two snakes. Yeah.
Okay, I think I'm done. I kind of want to add blushies. Okay, I'll add, I'll add a little,
I got another footprint. I'll add, I'll add a little bit of pink blushies and then I'll be done,
because I feel like it would fit nicely with this pink. My pet is not doing great, so the thought
of suffering that every couple of years gives an incredible amount of respect for you and your love
for your rats. Thank you. I don't know, it's um, it is hard, but like, the happy times kind of like,
um, overshadow the sad times kind of, you know. Thank you for the membership. Thank you.
Bronx is New York City. What about Bronx?
What about little dots in the back that look like stars around the cat?
That's going to be hard. I don't have that much, um,
I don't have that much, um, control. Um,
it's really hard to, it's, it's a, it's, um, much harder to paint on a shirt than it is on a canvas.
It's a lot less, um, you know, the shirt, the shirt moves around a lot, um, and so,
yeah, um, I'm trying to, I'm trying to be like simple.
Eh, huh, dammit, I got pink on this.
There's lots of rats in the Bronx. I'm not going to go all the way to New York City for a rat.
Like I said, I could find one in my backyard if I try hard enough.
Even if it hurts, it's better to feel something than nothing. Real and true, real and true.
That's exactly how I feel. Dammit, I put way too much pink out.
Okay, we're going to do a little bit of pink.
Pizza rat? Every rat will, will take the pizza. Rats will eat anything. They will all eat the pizza.
Is this a good pink? I feel like that must be a little dark. Can you even see me mixing? Oh, you can.
The rats in New York City are as big as house cats. Did you know there's actually like different
species of rats that have started evolving, evolving specific to New York City?
Yeah, isn't that crazy? The rats are winning, guys.
They're evolving to take over.
Oh man, I didn't mix enough.
Aw, so cute.
Did I fuck it up? Did I fuck it up with the blush?
Aw, let me mix more.
Did I just ruin it? Do you think it looks bad? Be honest. Should I make it more pink?
I'm pretty sure the only New York City rat that matters is Master Splinter. I don't know who that
is. Is that the rat from Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles or something?
Cats don't blush? Well, this one does because it's an anime cat.
I don't know. Should I? Okay, let me try it. It looks good to me. It looks fine.
You're lying. You're lying to my face. Let me try to even it out.
Oh, this is like the opposite of even. I need to make the other one bigger now.
There we go. Is that cute? Say yes. Say yes.
I think I got to add more here. There we go.
That was so cute. I think it's cute. I don't know. For a quick little painting, I think it's cute.
It's cute. I feel like it's cuter in person on stream. It doesn't look as cute. I don't know why.
I kind of feel like... I don't know. Do you think?
Do you think the blush is too close to the eyes or is it okay?
It's a little bit derpy looking. I'm not gonna lie. Gigi needs hugs. He does.
What was quick? The painting? Can you make a shirt for us too? Maybe one day.
I'd buy it. It's fine. Okay.
Let me see what it looks like.
Let me take it out of the cardboard.
Actually, that's a bad idea. Oh, it got stuck to the cardboard.
I'm trying to just fan it out as a regular shirt, but I'm scared I'm gonna get paint everywhere.
Just so you can see. Oh, I got paint here. Oh my god. I'm so stupid. Move the paint.
There. Just so you can see it as what it looks like as a shirt.
There's the shirt.
It's cute, I think. I don't know. It kind of looks like the thing one and thing two kind of shirts,
but it's cute enough. Maybe I should... I'm debating on whether or not I should draw
like a circle around it. I don't think I have black. Do I have black? If I had black, it would be really helpful.
No, I definitely don't have black. Damn it.
Okay, well, good enough. That's gonna be her shirt.
I think it looks better without an outline. Okay, if you say so. Let me try to clean up a
little bit because I still want to chat. Oh, should I chat on the floor? Maybe I'll just chat on the
floor. Hold on. I wanted to clean up a little bit and sit in my chair so we can chat a little bit,
but maybe I'll just chat while on the floor. Hold on. There.
Okay, and I'm gonna turn off the camera and move it away from me.
And just chat like this. Okay, on the floor still.
Let me open chat. Hold on.
Okay, and also go...
How do I...
Go to the live part of the stream.
Okay, there we go. This is on the floor floor time. What the fuck did PewDiePie call it floor gang?
Hi, cutie. You need to wear it and take a pic. I'm not gonna wear it. I'm not gonna wear it.
It's for my mom. And plus, my mom likes really tight shirts.
I got a small just for her, and I hate tight shirts. I hate it. It makes me so uncomfortable.
Rant about women's shirts, but I don't know if it's a women's shirt. I haven't checked,
but women's shirts are just so uncomfortable to me because they make them smaller specifically
because it's a women's shirt, but not only do they make them smaller, like I know,
oh naturally women are smaller than men. Whatever. I don't care. But not only do they make them smaller
in size, like fitted shirts like for women like hug your waist, and that makes me feel really
claustrophobic around my waist, and not only do they hug your waist, they have really, really small
sleeves. Like if it's a t-shirt, the sleeve area, like the armpit area is really, really tight,
and the sleeve, if it's a t-shirt, the sleeve is like tiny. Like it's not even a t-shirt, it's like
a tank top with a little bit of extra fabric because it barely goes over your fucking shoulders.
And so I hate women's t-shirts, and I hate women's shirts in general, but my mom loves them,
so I specifically got like a really small shirt for her.
Um, you need big bros long shirts? I do. I do. I don't wear women's t-shirts. I, uh,
I don't because I hate them so much. I know what you mean. Yeah, tight sleeves, tight sleeves,
and also like tight armpit, like my fucking armpit is getting suffocated here. I'm a sweater, like
there's not enough fabric in, in my armpit to like, um, catch all this sweat. Like it's
hugging my armpit, and it's making me sweaty, and there's just not enough fabric on this t-shirt
to catch all my armpit sweat. Women's clothes seems so adversal to people who are supposed
to be wearing them. It does, in general, yeah, it does. Oh my god, I just got sent a link by one
of my Vtuber friends about Vtuber drama. I love drama.
I did see that situation. Yes, Kaifu. I'll never know what we're talking about.
She just sent me some drama. We, we talk about Vtuber drama.
Tell us if mom loves this shirt. She'll like it. She'll like it.
Drama spill it? No, I'm not allowed to. I'm not allowed to. I shouldn't, but I like it. I like,
I like, I like the drama because, how do I say this, um, oopsies, I clicked on the wrong thing,
hold on. I like the drama not because it involves me or like is related to me, but I feel like,
I feel like, I don't know how to describe it without telling you what it is, whatever,
whatever, I won't talk about it. I'm just happy about it. I'm so evil. I'm so evil, oh my god.
I know. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. It's not my big drama. It doesn't involve me at all. It doesn't
involve Veeler or anything. Don't worry. Immular new drama channel. No, she even wanted to do that.
Oh, I'm not, she didn't want to do specifically drama. She wanted to do Vtuber news.
Yeah, I love Vtuber drama on Twitter. It's my, it's my favorite too. It's always so petty. It's
always so petty and stupid.
Girls look cuter in baggy shirts anyways. They do. They do. The smaller, the more expensive they are.
It's insane. I have a pigeon. Oh my god. He costs more than my dog and two cats together.
Are you tall by any chance? Not really. I'm not short either.
Fine. Keep your secrets.
Drama is good if bad. People are exposed. Unfortunately, this drama is not about
any exposed stuff really. Vtuber culture is like a non-stop soap opera. It is, it is,
and that's why I love it. I don't like being involved in drama myself. I keep to myself a lot.
I keep to myself, but I love reading about other people's drama. Oh no. Hello? Oh, there we go.
I love reading about other people's drama. I know it's bad. I know I shouldn't say that,
but I like reading about other people's drama.
I'm surprised Shibi hasn't done that yet. I think she's planning it. She's definitely
planning it. She really wants to, it seems like. I'm also here about the drama around the big
agencies. I hear about that too, but I also like the drama around the indies as well.
Waiting for the Emmy apology stream? I don't think I really said anything or done anything.
I need to apologize for other than like existing, but I'm like not gonna apologize. I'm not gonna
apologize. So yeah. V-Tweeter drama. Some dramas just delicious to watch. It's delicious when it
doesn't, it's delicious when it doesn't involve me, you know? Everyone hears about the drama with
big agencies. That's the big agency's blessings slash curse. Yeah, yeah, that's true. But people
hear about the drama with small agencies too, which is not as much. My phone is dying soon.
It's all fun and games until death threats are involved?
Yeah, that's true, obviously. As long as it stays a leafling read. Hi! We finished painting the
shirt. Sorry, now we're just yapping a little bit. Yeah, we finished painting the shirt, but hello!
Jimmy Ray! Hi, leaflings! Unless someone does something truly horrible or illegal, I don't care
about drama. That's fair. I don't care, but I like it. I love it. I'm kind of, I know I shouldn't,
I'm evil, not evil, but I'm uh, I'm bad for that. It's a bad habit of mine.
Hi! What did you guys, what were you guys up to? I gotta, I gotta stalk a little bit.
Oh, are you playing Sonic Heroes?
Oh, you're playing vermin, vermin tide. Wait, what's vermin tide?
That's why they made drama shows. Yeah! Sonic was yesterday. Immediately slipping up drama.
It does get out of hand fast. Where it stops being drama starts being court proceedings or
international news. I, how did the shirt come out? It came out well. It came out cute. You can go back
in the stream and look at it if you, um, if you, am I looking at you when I look down? Hold on.
I think I'm looking down. I'm looking at the, at the, the, now I'm looking at you. I don't know.
My, um, my iPhone's like at a, at a different um, height than usual.
We're trying to convince me to spill the tea.
Vermin tide is killing bipedal rap people. I'm never playing that game then.
Isn't drama like the best selling category or anything? It is
Jimmy Peace. Why are you calling, why are you calling me Jimmy? Is it because I called myself Jimmy one time?
Yeah, it's, I, I think Vtuber drama is mostly contained in the Vtuber community. The only time
I've ever seen Vtuber drama hit like, not mainstream audience, but like more people outside of the
community is with the Salen situation. I've, I've, I was scrolling through TikTok and I saw
someone completely unrelated to Vtubers cover that topic. Thank you for the two months of membership.
Thank you. To be fair, the rats are very evil. That's, that's fine. They can be evil. Nothing
wrong with being a little evil. Everyone, everyone deserves to be a little evil sometimes.
That was the only time I actually saw drama hit outside of the Vtuber community. It mostly stays
inside of the Vtuber community. Yeah, yeah, Salen's termination and like everything that followed
after that, that situation. Yeah, how dare you call rats evil? Not in this part too.
A doki drama is what made aware Vtubers even exist. Now I'm here watching you all. Oh, interesting.
Oh, there was like three dramas this morning. Three. Oh, you're deep into, you're deep into Vtuber
drama, aren't you? Three this morning. Yeah. And Ludwig talked about Rusha. Oh, okay. Wait,
when Rusha graduated or like the thing with Rusha and Mafumafu, what, what, what thing?
I don't know how big the Mafumafu Rusha stuff was. I feel like it was kind of big.
Doki drama, Gora at the stadium, mm-hmm, Gora at the stadium was kind of big too.
For sure. Yeah, there is some old Vtuber drama every day and I love it. I love it so much. Like
the, the, I forgot her name. The girl that like accused someone of copying her and it was like,
I don't know. I'm surprised I never got, I never got canceled for copying, uh,
uh, what's your name? Muffet. I was Walmart Muffet. Oh God, Rusha.
Rusha didn't graduate, sorry. Terminated. Termination. Rusha got, Rusha got terminated.
Sorry, you're right, you're right. It was big in Japan? I mean, yeah, Rusha was pretty big, right?
Yeah, um, no, I'm talking about, uh, there was a shy Lily situation, but there was also the,
another one more recent than that. She became a terminator. Yeah, she was, I think she still
is the biggest hololive earner, which is crazy. Um, but honestly, I watched, okay, listen, I don't
condone anything that, um, hold on, I need to move my ring light, hold on. Come on. Uh, turn that
freaking light lower. Okay, I don't condone anything that Rusha has done, but I watched some of her clips
and she's good at what she does. Okay, that's all I'm going to say. She's good at what she does,
and I see why she was popular, um, because she's good at what she does. I watched her clips and I
was like, damn, this girl knows how to, this girl knows what people like to hear kind of, you know,
this girl, this girl knows how to, how to role play, I guess, or I guess in her situation,
it wasn't even role playing, it was just real. Um, the Twitch drama just has everyone panicking
too in the Vtuber space and streamers in general. Wait, what Twitch drama? Moist Critical mentioned
Rusha, really? Yeah, when, when like, when like, YouTubers, um, and like, Twitch streamers mentioned
Vtuber drama, that's when you know it got big. Oh, Coco had the most, she was second, wait, really?
Your experience is Vtuber drama happening more than regular streamer drama? Because I've never
interacted with streaming at all before VTubers, and I don't know if it's actually more drama than
IRL. I don't know actually. I feel like there is more drama in the Vtuber community, but I've never
interacted with the IRL streamer community that much. Rusha is not just the biggest hollow earner,
she's still one of the 10 biggest earners of all time on YouTube. Holy shit.
She does need therapy. Azman Gold's got a whole video on any color drama. Oh, yeah,
that's when you know it's big. She actually got engaged with a fan IRL? Rusha?
Like right now or before? I know she sold um, she sold engagement rings, right? That was, listen,
I know some people are like, ew, that's so cringe. Why would she, I think it's funny. I think it's
funny. I think it's campy. I know she was married. I know she was married. I still, like,
like when, I think when it came out that she used to sell engagement rings as like merch,
people were like, what the fuck? Who would buy an engagement ring? I think it's campy.
Um, did you see how Mikko acted in the rest server? The streamers in that server used
her as well. Cali was crazy. I don't know what that means. How does she act?
Twitch, two Twitch dramas going on going. The karaoke ban and the anyone can collab with anyone
else, whether the second streamer wants it or not thing. Oh, I didn't know there was a karaoke ban.
I mean, there's basically a karaoke ban on YouTube too because your video gets automatically
demonetized. Um, I did hear about the collab thing. I don't quite know what it is, but I did
hear that like you have to, it's automatically like turned on. I'm not sure if that's true.
Like something about like, okay, I have to turn off the slides too much for me. Oh, I'm so old.
I can't have lights in my face. Sorry. Um, it was like, if you, I got to turn off this other light
too. Hold on. Where's the light? Oh, that's so much better. It was like, actually, maybe I should
try and keep it on. It was like, uh, you can like request a collab with anyone if you're both,
if you're both, um, Twitch affiliates, affiliates, is that what it was?
Where's our ring in me? I don't know if we have the budget for rings now. Come on.
She was just unaware of how rust is as a game we got, but her when people were mean to her,
when she wasn't being helpful and she ended up crying. Oh, shit. Oh, begging to be part of
people's groups and getting KOS. I don't know what that means. On site. Killed on site. Is that what
it means? She stole resources from to give to. We need a member only drama gossip stream. No,
because it's still going to get clipped and people are going to be like, oh my God, it means such a drama whore.
It is. Yeah, it was that one. You can just give me a strip of aluminum foil shaped like a ring.
You can trick the system, but not turn it off. And apparently the ambassador that is pushing
it is being outed as a creep and a groomer of other VTubers. What?
What? Holy crap.
Her original clan found out she was kicked out and then went around the rest of the server
chasing people. That's strange.
These rules are a lot harsher and can strike your channel while live, not just vods.
That's weird. Karaoke. Why do, why do, why do they hate Karaoke's? I know a lot of VTubers aren't
good at singing, but a lot of VTubers are good at singing because that's like a huge part of
being a VTuber is singing. So like, why do they hate us and Karaoke's?
You have to set it to favorites only and then never add anyone to favorites. That's so weird.
It apparently turns your webcam on or something. I heard that, but that's,
that's too weird. That's something that I feel like Twitch wouldn't make. I don't know about it
because I'm no longer on YouTube. I mean on Twitch, but that feels like something Twitch wouldn't do.
Like why would they make a thing that turns your webcam on automatically
for collabs? That sounds weird and strange and stupid. I feel like they wouldn't do that.
Ahem. Twitch doesn't hate Karaoke's. They hate VTubers.
Possibly. I don't know. I feel like Twitch is just really inconsistent, but so is YouTube.
Like every big platform is inconsistent.
It turns your camera on if you are the person who is requesting the collab, not if you accept.
Why? I mean, first of all, why? I feel like it's really, it's really strange to do this whole
collab request thing. Like if it's your friend and they're streaming and you want to collab with them,
just text them and be like, Hey, let's stream together. You know,
I don't know. Does it like show both streams at once? Like how does the collab, like if
both people do the collab, how does it work? Does it show both streams at once? Is that how
it's different? Because then I would understand. But if it's just like, like what does it do? I'm confused.
You just have to have express permission for the copyright holders, which might as well be banned.
I won't go text Taylor Swift and ask her if I can use her music in my karaoke.
An archive does not enough. You can get Bong to live if it's anything other than a public domain
composition or your own original music. What the fuck? What if I pitch it up and call it a
nightcore remix and then sing it like that? I got it. Oh, hold on. Okay. I've been leaning like a shrimp.
The creep pushing this feature also has a history of going into small vtubers chat
with his ambassador medal and forcing himself into voice calls. What the fuck?
That's so weird. That's so strange.
The webcam thing sounds like fearmongering. It kind of does because I feel like,
I feel like Twitch wouldn't do that. That's stupid.
Nightcore loophole, literally. And people shit on me for liking nightcore, bro.
On popular opinion, I think nightcore is good. I think nightcore is good music. I like to listen
to nightcore and I think it's catchy. And I think people who don't like it or no, I think people who
adamantly are against nightcore just hate fun. They hate fun and they hate joy and they hate a
little bit of silly Billy goofing around. Okay. A lot of people really hate nightcore and don't
think it's real music. Sure, whatever, but it's just, it's just, turn off your brain for a second.
It's literally just, it's just sped up and higher pitched. Like it's fun. You like anime girls that
are high pitched, so you should like nightcore. Like what's wrong with it? It's fine. There's
really good nightcore songs, but also a ton of really bad ones. Of course there is. Any song can
sound both good and bad nightcore or a fight. It's just the editor that did it, you know?
Like, same with any song can sound good or bad. Slow down. It's just really depends on who edited
it and who mixed it and who made it, you know, sound like that. They hate wonder. They do.
What the freak is nightcore? Nightcore is just like a remix of a song. It's like a genre of
remix where you speed it up and make it higher pitched. And that's basically all you do. You
can do other things and I've seen artists do a lot of really cooler edits with nightcore and still
put it in the nightcore genre, but generally it's just sped up and higher pitched. Why do people care
if people like something they don't? They're buttholes. They're annoying and they're buttholes.
They're annoying buttholes. They hate fun like I told you they hate fun. They hate me specifically
having fun. Yeah, there's good songs and bad songs in every genre, yeah.
Nightcore sues the neurotypical brain? The neurotypical? I don't know. You think neurotypical is like
nightcore? Silly Billy mentioned. I don't know. I just had a friend of mine that was like really
judgy about me liking nightcore. Even though it's like it's popular for a reason. It's because it's
catchy, okay? It's because it's catchy and because it's good. And now I'm thinking of a specific
nightcore song that I don't remember but it was really catchy. It was a weird part of my teens
what a time to be a weave. I listened to a lot of it too. We should do it. We should do a nightcore
karaoke one day. That would be that would be peak cringe nightcore karaoke where I only sing
nightcore songs. I don't know how I would do that because most nightcore songs don't have
instrumentals at all. But I should do that. Most nightcore songs don't have instrumentals
but I'll just sing over the nightcore part. It'd be a good breathing exercise. Am I the only one
that unironically likes Eurobeat? Okay, Eurobeat I don't know what that is. Is that just like European
music? Is that what is that what JoJo Siwa's new song is like? Is that Eurobeat?
If you initiate the knock knock request your webcam automatically activates why though?
Why? Why? Is that a glitch or is that on purpose? Because like why? What's the point of that?
What if you don't have a webcam? Like my computer doesn't have a webcam so it does nothing?
Like I have to I have to plug in an external webcam.
That would be very unbranded.
Some people really go from I don't like this to no one should like this. Like they're the
single person who gets to decide what's good slash fun. True, true. Some people are just
um downers, downers. That's what they are. Still unclear about who JoJo Siwa is. JoJo Siwa is a
child star not star but kind of a child celebrity who got popular from dance moms which was a show
about kids dancing and I think she also did pageants I don't know. And now she she's still
made like kids content for a really long time but now she's more adult and she's trying to like
break into the adult sphere of like stuff like celebrity activities like making music
but everyone's just shitting on her because she's doing it in a really cringy way and also
I don't think this is mean. People make fun of her singing a lot and I feel like okay I can't
I can't judge her singing because like who what do I know about singing but I do feel like she
wasn't taught to sing any other way than like kids song way if that makes sense like like like like
like um
I literally like kids bop kind of singing like she wasn't taught how to sing like actually
sing I feel like she sings like kids bop kind of style and so you can kind of hear it in her
first song at least and then she's made other songs and she's had drama about like buying the
rights to songs and then singing them herself quote unquote people are still feel like sometimes
she doesn't completely replace the vocals with her own voice which is fair JoJo's bizarre adventure
no I thought you're gonna end the sentence that JoJo Siwa was a child she was a child
she's no longer a child but she was a child
eurobeat is running in the 90s oh eurobeat is what nightcore usually makes songs sound like
like you are you saying eurobeat sounds like sounds like nightcore
when you see the memes of people drifting in cars that music
if I if I if that's what I'm thinking of it kind of sounds cringe it's basically gas gas gas what
does that mean what does gas gas mean doom posting what me
she's trying yeah she's trying to Miley Cyrus but she's doing it in a little bit of a cringe
way and people are making fun of her for it activating someone's webcam without their
express consent is a violation of privacy and theory but I feel like rights on the internet
are becoming more and more a matter of opinion that's true there's a new genre called sex trance
or hexed trance that's very nightcore-esque and I love it that sounds so that name sounds so tiktok
sex trance that sounds like a word that was made up on tiktok
I'm I OMG she doesn't know gas gas gas is a very iconic song
just listen to gas gas gas someone red pill her on an initial deep what
my phone's gonna die soon so five percent sorry I'm covering up my camera gas gas gas
manual gas gas gas Manuel is a manual manual oh my god I'm sorry
Manuel um is this it I'm listening on my phone hold on is this it
is this it yes
it just sounds like an anime opening
yeah it just sounds like an anime opening
ha ha skip to the chorus where when's the chorus
sorry
the lyrics are so literal and like Taylor Swiftie I'm gonna step on the gas oh DMCA
oops oops oops I forgot I know you could hear it I didn't think about DMCA
sorry I'm too used to never getting strikes I might have to cut that part out of the stream
I might have to cut that part out of the stream sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry
yeah I I I completely forgot I forget sometimes oopsie poopsie
oopsie doopsie
yes it's your fault you told me about gas gas gas it's your fault
um lyrics written by people who whose English is definitely not their first language I can
tell I'm gonna step on the gas of my car
do you like my car your beat was huge in japan at the time that makes sense probably because
the lyrics are super simple
don't be sorry pimpels just have strike PTSD that's fair I'm sorry can you sign sing that next
karaoke stream I I'm kind of uncomfortable with singing songs that I'm not familiar with
so I'd probably have to listen to that song over and over again and I'm not gonna lie that song
sounds really annoying I do I am planning songs for another karaoke stream um I want to do a
stream where I practice like uh deeper songs so like I have my playlist here hold on
because I feel like I sound better like that like at least it's easier for me so like um
rises the moon by is it liana flores or like from the start by lafi because people wanted
me to sing that while not drunk um washing machine heart by mitzky lots of mitzky songs
um stuff like that um the song from semen universe I don't know is that cringe
probably a little bit probably a little bit I'm more a lot more lafi songs is it lafi or lafi
lafi lafi I don't know but I want to sing songs sung by women with slightly deeper voices
um because that's like my comfortable range
some songs from le miserable would be awesome maybe
lofi no la lafi like the artist just saw the stream title is your mom still keeping you at
gunpoint yes she's always doing that from the start was amazing in the drunk karaoke I can't
imagine how good it would be when you aren't drunk I hope it would be better I hope it's better I hope
so I hope so I hope it's better I think it will be I think it will be maybe not that much better
but I think a little bit better at least I hope I don't know I I pause I actually don't hear my I
try not I try to avoid recording myself while singing because um that's cringe to hear but
um I didn't want to show you something because strani sent it to me earlier so I wanted to show
you remember how I gave you a um I gave you a uh a sneak peek at one of my song covers I wanted
to give you another sneak peek because it's not done yet the mix isn't done yet but it's like
almost there so I wanted to show you another sneak peek this is um kill yourself by po bernum
now the song is about two minutes long I feel like I don't know should I give you a slightly longer
sneak peek the four night battle pass one uh just got sent over to be um like made into an MV I guess
so I don't know how long that'll take but hopefully it won't take long um maybe like
do what to myself k y s by bo bernum by bo bernum the song
I feel like I should show you uh you listen let you listen to like a little bit longer version
than like just two seconds like last time um maybe like 10 seconds hold on I have to pause
it real quick or no I have to download it first I don't know it's 10 seconds too long you still
gotta I still gotta you know I still gotta tease you a little bit
what about the filthy frank one of the same name I could I don't know I'm I could do more meme songs
maybe if these ones do good at least I might do more but I don't think they'll do good
don't tell sturdy I said that I just feel like song covers in general don't get that popular
um unless they're like parody songs and maybe but I feel like song covers in general don't
don't get that popular unless you're already a big vtuber then they will get popular but if you're
not then I feel like they don't get that popular I don't know it's just me though it's just me
being a doomer and a pessimist um you know it's just me being pessimistic oh no my face is bad
damn it you heard it why is my face bad so low okay you heard a little bit no okay
okay
it's maybe I should turn down the echo more and I feel like it's very echoey um clip it
um I'll I'll give you I'll give you I get it I don't usually like covers I'm okay with
listening to covers sung by vtubers but I um I just feel like I don't know they don't they
don't get traction which is fine they're fun to do for people who like to sing so you know
okay I'll give you a 10 second 10 second little little a clip have you ever felt sad or lonely
have you ever felt two feet tall have you ever thought man if only how is anybody else at all
they like to kick okay that's it that's it that's it that's it that's it that's all you get
did you like it
that's that's it's not done but um that's a little bit of it
sounds really cute thank you honestly the mixers always do a good job of making me sound um
it's listenable listenable I need it on loop
you can have it on loop when it comes out I don't know when that will be but
it's out of my hands so I don't know when it will come out but hopefully soon I don't know a month
why don't have four DMs who's DMing me
sorry I know my model is sleeping because I'm sitting on the floor so I have to look all the
way up to see my monitors thank you for coming up in pal honestly it's impressive to me how you
well you can sing even when you're singing at a hard pitch then you're more comfortable
it's impressive to me too because it's really fucking hard like talking like this is fine and I
I'm comfortable um but singing is like completely different I I uh I have to position my like
throat I guess in like a completely different way um and it's it's it's kind of uncomfortable
and it's not um it's not sustainable for me for like karaoke's um or just casual singing I I like
it's it's hard it's really hard um so you think it'd be easy you would think it'd be like chill
but no it's it's really hard actually drama plus fired plus mom me fired what do you mean
in me of the floor what's your wisdom um
I'm not a wise person
uh I'm not a wise person at all
um
if you're uh
I don't take don't let other people take pictures of you because it will they will make you look
really ugly and self-conscious uh don't let other people take pictures of you that's my
wisdom you'll you'll you'll be like wow this looks awful especially your mom but anyone in general
you should be in control of your own pictures because otherwise you're gonna look bad there you
go
wisdom kiss your sister kiss your sister too that's my wisdom that's my wisdom
that's fair never looked good in pictures never look you it's very normal to not look good in
pictures that other people take of you because it's like they don't know they don't know what
makes you look good you know they don't know your angles they don't know I don't know they don't
you know they don't know how to make you look good they just take the picture you know yeah
but you took good pics of your cousins right of your cousin I did take good pictures of my cousin
because um she like I said she kind of just looks like a model naturally I didn't I didn't have to
try too hard to make her look good I wasn't like posing her she already knew what to do she's she's
very uh you know she's she's like she's got that model look you know I don't even know what
makes me look good that's okay too but your people who take pictures of you will like make you look
even worse only let me take pictures of you I'll make you look good yes especially for ID and driving
driving license pictures oh my god I look awful I look so awful I've had people do double takes
at my ID because I don't look like that in real life like in real life I look so much different
than my ID and my idea I look like a fucking I look like a I look like a kappa I look like a kappa
that just crawled out from under a bridge but in real life I don't look like that it's just
it looks bad because someone else took the picture and also I was like not really ready to take a
picture that day I wasn't I wasn't planning on taking a picture I wish we lived in I wish like
more governments were nice about taking pictures of you for your ID because like in Korea they let
you fucking photoshop your ID did you know that why would they do that why would they do that here
in Canada you can't even smile you're not allowed to smile you're not allowed to wear like I think
you're not allowed to wear like a lot of makeup I'm not quite sure but um like in Korea they have
like professional photo booths that will make you look beautiful and and and photoshop you into
looking sorry I know I'm liking a little bit photoshopping you into looking beautiful here it's
like you go to the nearest shoppers and they like put you in front of the fucking chip aisle and take
a picture of you I'm taking a picture of you right there in the store like I'm sure they have
professional not professional but I'm sure they have better boots here but I feel like that's what
people
shoppers is a drug store by the way in Canada shoppers is a drug store here
yeah and they just take one there's like no redoes like they just they just take one
what's the point of an ID then I don't know I don't know my ID makes me look like a gangster
it really doesn't look like like your real self at all
shoppers does your driver's license CIBC does mine but shoppers did my passport
I think so I don't I think they can I think they can take any ID photos I'm not sure but yeah like
they they don't they don't they don't do you any favors at all yeah you only get one I said that
already I applied for a US visa and the requirements for the photo were insanely strict they are very
strict with photos yeah yeah you can't smile yeah
is to pretend that you're the person in the photo of course
look at a drug store issues passports not actual drugs but like a drug store like a convenience store
I don't know why they do that but they do I guess Immy Lord I know that because I used to work at one
I used to work at a shoppers and I would have people come in to take their ID photos
and I would feel bad for them because of course they always look like shit in those ID photos
okay I need I need to shut my yap
those streaming right now
a bunch of people were streaming when I started but now they're not anymore what the frick
there's Umi why did I sound like that why did I moan like that when I said Umi Umi
are you gay why are you acting so gay I can't wait to goon tipped five dollars
in the goon after stream
I'll try to goon after stream too we can goon together okay Umi's playing um
is that stardew valley what is that I'm not quite sure what that is
at least I got a weight background not like it helps though yeah
I love cheering you yep I'm happy
I'll go with Umi I'll go with Umi oh sorry I keep losing tracking because I'm looking
up at my pewter because I'm on the floor it's hot on the floor
it's lonely all the way up top on the floor
uh this one
ah fuck also I feel like Loki I feel like my redirects haven't been working anymore
have they been working I feel like they haven't been working
can't goon tonight gotta get gotta get a shower and go to bed
I'll try to goon I don't know I don't know if I'll be in the mood but I I planned to goon tonight
I wrote it on my schedule I tried to make a schedule of content to make it I wrote it on my
schedule that I need to I need to record a goonings shit I went on my schedule I scheduled my gooning
just like I scheduled my breakdowns um but sometimes I cannot do them I don't know we'll see
raids are broken across the board on youtube oh they haven't been working for strawney either
okay so here's what I'll do
um oh I didn't see the raid banner but got redirected after the stream ended anyways
okay so here's what I'll do I will copy the link and paste it in chat when I'm um
when I end stream so that way you can just click on the link um right after what the
fuck is this ad so that way you can just click on the link and be copy and be directed to her stream
okay okay all right I'll see you tomorrow I think at 12 for um a dress to impress stream with roblox
quick take my money before you kick me out for your gooning session thank you thank you for the
ten dollars thank you for giving me your money um oh my god look at your fucking phone in me hi
okay oh my god it's still disconnecting um yeah I'll see you tomorrow for dress to impress with uh
uh really uh I forgot
really uh aliyah and laffy pie uh yeah sorry um yeah I'll see you at 12 I think that's what it is
I don't know I always get it wrong but I think that's what it is I've never played roblox before
surprisingly I know that's crazy isn't it I wasn't bored in the roblox I was kind of bored in the
roblox generation but I thought it was just a cheap version of minecraft so I was like I'd rather play
minecraft um but yeah
that was an embarrassing sound um
I miss you I'm not gone yet I will be gone soon though okay see you tomorrow I love you sleep well um
you did good today thank you for spending time with me um okay bye bye
do